Nos dicen que: "Pilar tiene 85 pulgadas de
listón. Ella le da a su amigo Nico, 19 pulgadas
de listón. ¿Cuánto listón le queda a Pilar?"
Pausa el video y trata de resolverlo. Muy bien,
ahora hagámoslo juntos. Pilar comienza con 85
pulgadas de listón, y podríamos representar eso
con lo que se conoce como Diagrama de cajas
-supongo que podrías llamarlo un Diagrama
de listón en este caso-. Digamos que el ancho de
este rectángulo representa la longitud del listón
de Pilar que son 85 pulgadas, justo aquí. Ella le
da a su amigo Nico 19 pulgadas del listón, así que
regala 19 pulgadas. Podríamos pensar que regalar
19 pulgadas -no lo estoy haciendo exactamente,
pero para darnos una idea, 19 pulgadas podría ser
más o menos así, estas son las 19 pulgadas que
Pilar regala-. ¿Cuánto listón le queda a Pilar?
Bueno, sería esta sección que tenemos aquí. Ahora,
¿cómo podemos calcular cuánto le queda, a cuánto
equivale este signo de interrogación? Bueno,
hay un par de maneras de pensar en esto. Podríamos
decir que 19 más el signo de interrogación es
igual a 85. Déjame escribirlo: 19 + ?, que es lo
que estamos tratando de calcular, = 85, así que la
cantidad que regaló más la cantidad que le queda
es igual a 85. O podríamos ver que si empezamos
con 85 y tuviéramos que quitar 19, bueno, esto es
lo que nos queda; entonces también podríamos decir
que el signo de interrogación, que es la cantidad
que nos queda, es = 85 - 19. Entonces, ¿cuánto es
85 - 19? Bueno, hay muchas formas en que podemos
calcularlo. Una forma de hacerlo es reescribir 85
como 80 + 5, separamos esencialmente la posición
de las decenas de la posición de las unidades,
tenemos 8 decenas, que es lo mismo que 80, y 5
unidades, y luego reescribiremos 19 como 10 y
9. Entonces, si estoy restando 19, realmente estoy
restando 10 y restando 9. Ahora, ¿por qué es útil
hacerlo así? Bueno, es bastante sencillo decir que
80 - 10 = 70, 8 decenas menos 1 decena es igual
a 7 decenas. Y así podríamos reescribir esto como
70 + 5 - 9. Ahora, si trato de calcular cuánto es
5 - 9 nos metemos en un problema, porque 9 es más
grande que 5. Pero ¿y si reescribiéramos 9 en dos
partes? Si decimos que 9 es lo mismo que 4 + 5,
entonces restar 9 es lo mismo que restar 5 y luego
restar 4, y eso lo hace un poco más fácil, porque
sabemos que 5 - 5 = 0, y así podemos reescribir
esto como 70 - 4. Ahora, ¿cuál va a ser el
resultado? Bueno, sabemos que 10 - 4 = 6, entonces
70 - 4 será igual a 66. Y hemos terminado. Esta es
la cantidad de listón que le queda: 66 pulgadas.